Ma'Am,
the Joe Rogan experience day.
Joe Rogan podcast by all day
you introduced us
my,
we are all balls of steel.
Bloody balls.
Bloody balls of steel shut offs.
Duncan Trussell.
Oh,
the hardest deal is the ball of steel hammer.
Tom Crane and Lance Armstrong could form a true at trio.
Oh my,
what's it called?
Korn ferry Avengers trio.
It's true.
I want to see a tree yet.
You know,
quartet sounds better than trio.
Trio.
Sounds like the next time we come in,
get to take one more.
So all the way the working title.
Yeah.
Uh,
what you going to do now?
What are you going to do now,
ladies and gentlemen on Twitter?
Now's your time to be heard,
right?
Ben and Suzanne or listening?
Yeah.
And judging you.
Just kidding.
We're not except you.
Oh,
coming down.
Okay.
Ah,
yeah.
Okay.
Si.
Very
wait,
you can't change him.
Okay.
Yay.
Yes.
Key.
The key
to the gay.
Yeah.
I'm staying here.
Ooh.
Wow.
Okay.
You can't change him.
Hmm.
Mouth.
Ooh,
baby.
Yeah.
Okay.
Awesome.
I really liked that one.
That was great.
Cool.
Wow.
That's bad ass.